I guess doing very good I think you're
not sick of each other oh absolutely
when you're shooting like this like when
you are with somebody for that long in
the way that you guys were together even
if you love the person you're like God
just go I think we probably did have
days like that where we would sort of
purposefully probably leave each other
alone
we actually got on set you know it's
like a relationship you know you have to
give each other space
you know we've both been through that
with other actors I'm sure where you
work closely and you just understand
each other yeah I do dad jokes all the
time
it's just wines hair up and right enough
with everything they can do in movies
now and you both know what they can do
with the movie and with a green screen
and with the guy on a computer Y subject
yourselves to this and shoot this this
way in that cold as you can tell at the
end of the day you can tell us that
means green screen or if it's you know a
bunch of different shots cobbled
together or stolen from another movie
you can you can you can tell and yeah
and also it would have had such an
impact on I think the characters and the
truth of the story you know and and we
really were at 10,000 feet and we really
were freezing cold and we really were
you know surviving up there and it was
very very very difficult and is it true
did it mess you up a little bit were you
having like were you having nightmares
were you that's I would have quite a few
I don't have quite a few weird
nightmares we both had sort of strange
you know cold weather where I would I
had a real thing about ice because you
know well as you know being a Canadian
you know those frozen rivers they are
thick you know and where we were in
Invermere there's a beautiful frozen
lake there and you know my husband and
my son would go and play on the frozen
lake and after doing our ice hole see
and I would like to know actually can
you just not do that sorry we'll just
would you mind awfully just just so I
don't have to think about it
but you know it happens and how I mean
you watch this movie and you kind of go
through the process but you question how
resourceful you actually are as a person
after doing this movie did you figure
out how to build a fire from nothing yet
you'd still do you have that skill or no
I already know how to do that he is
rubbish I'm completely the truth is that
now after making this movie and working
with Kate more than anything else yes
like I'm brushing up my survival skills
because if I could choose at any one to
go down in a player became really
yes-man like would she be the we got to
get out of here how to make a meal out
of the seats I would I'd and you know
I'm in a city boy you know yeah and then
you know I'm not on mountains but this
after making this from F
newfound respect for the outdoorsy
people I have for sure so in that
situation the almond the chocolate or
the candy which one do you save is your
last all the chocolate every time it's
got to be right by the way we add lots
of candy on this you do oh my gosh why
guns why Maynard's wine gums especially
but actually towards the end anything
anything candy like really like I would
get into work and I think I'm not going
to eat chocolate for breakfast and then
I would write when you are shooting
altitude you can eat whatever you want
because you're burning so much and to be
honest you just need the cat you need
the calories and you need the fat and
the sugar that you know all of it but it
was interesting what you were just
saying about about nature because you
know it was spectacular where we were
filming it was absolutely beautiful and
I really found myself more than ever
before
utterly awestruck by how beautiful the
world is and in particular Canada love
Canada love Canadians